some bread a warm meal or even insults
migrants are getting helped from
individuals and institutions like in
this hostel in Mexico City Viviana
Gutierrez is one of those who turned out
today she drove a van overloaded with
clothes for women and children yeah
mucho you that you win it's gratifying
that a lot of people are helping it
brings out the humanity in us and it
pleases me to see the difference we're
making we're all very proud to be
Mexican Mexico has seen migrants bound
northwards who travel through the
country for decades this is a chance for
to express solidarity with foreigners we
have to deal with this acutely painful
situation to reach out to people passing
through who are in need Colombians and
Hondurans think that we reject them we
have to support each other because we
are all human beings and we feel for
them demos but these people haven't been
welcomed by everyone some have begun
lashing out at the migrants they have no
problems because they don't work if they
come here to contribute then they're
welcome it seems like they're having a
day at the beach they don't wear shirts
they throw away the food we give them
but they keep the beer many of them are
drunk urinating in public everywhere
Mexico cannot cope with receiving them I
hope that from now on officials check
their papers and give them what they
deserve and give us what we deserve
human rights are apparently worth more
than ours
some of the migrants have felt that lack
of sensitivity during their journey but
even so most say Mexico has offered them
good care now one person insulted us we
don't like that but I guess we have to
accept it
we are invading their country Mexico has
received us very well we're very proud
because it has given us all this support
we have not lacked food or clothing
Mexico a country divided like so many
others by migration